Democrats are making some major mistakes
right now really just completely
unforced errors and I want to dig into
this a little bit I did this as I
mentioned earlier this week we should
really be in the golden era of
resurgence for Democrats and it is
instead just bumbling foolishness and
already telegraphing the same mistakes
for 20/20 that we saw Democrats make in
2018 so to set the stage for you
we had the DNC disaster of 2016 right
absolute and total train wreck
interfering in the primary resignations
really bad for Democrats Inc or what I
like to call corporate Democrats and
then I told you last week that there are
Democratic donors that are reportedly
excited about California senator Kamala
Harris and I they're starting to give
her money for the 2020 presidential race
and I said you know no offense she seems
smart seems like a possibly interesting
candidate but we've got the midterms
coming up here right and anytime I hear
that Democratic donors are excited about
someone three years out I start to get
worried since that's exactly what got us
into this mess in the first place in
2016
cut to Monday Democrats announced a new
slogan called a better deal I thought it
was a disastrous slogan a better deal
could be sort of pushing back against
Trump who talks about how he will make
the best deals
but it felt vacuous and it already sort
of conceded the concept of deals to
Donald Trump others said you know David
it might be a reference to FDR's New
Deal but yet again a better deal better
isn't even necessarily good it could be
better but still bad right so it's a
totally weak slogan and the substance is
also really weak and again just to catch
you up on where we were on Monday this
new better deal from Democrats is going
to target job training programs which
Donald Trump has talked about and it's
not exactly what's going to get people
super excited about voting for you
Democrats want to renegotiate trade
deals which plays right into what Donald
Trump has talked been talking about and
it gets you into the weeds of how will
we renegotiate trade deals versus
how will they renegotiate trade deals
Democrats putting out as part of this
better deal more specific spending plans
for infrastructure which also
infrastructure is all well and good and
with peace and love but Trump has been
talking about infrastructure deals of
course in a totally crony istic cap
vulture capitalist way but it again gets
dent into the weeds having to be like
well our infrastructure spending plan is
better than trama infrastructure
spending plan so big win really for
anybody who believes in Trump's
worldview because Democrats would this
better deal essentially said hey we're
basically conceding that Trump is
talking about all the right issues but
we're going to explain to you how our
plans will actually be better than
Donald Trump's plans so this is where we
were up until Monday now it's been
reported that Senator Harris a camel
Harris just did a second tour through
the Hamptons of New York to meet with
so-called influential Democratic donors
I'll remind you that earlier this month
she met with Liz Robbins who's a top
Hillary Clinton bundler of donations she
was back in the Hamptons Hamptons this
weekend to meet more top Clinton donors
one anonymous Democratic donor said to
the hill that Harris is quote absolutely
going to run for president in 2020
another source said to page six that
quote she's on overdrive it's not just
about the money that's the easy part for
her she wants to meet the influential
she's reportedly already hired multiple
former Clinton staffers and she's also
seemingly trying to circumvent what
could be a Bernie Sanders style
challenger popping up in twenty to
twenty she reportedly paid four hundred
thousand dollars to a company called the
revolution messaging which is the same
firm that built Bernie Sanders is
digital and branding strategy while he
was basically experiencing a media
blackout back in 2015 and once again
it's this centrist moderate non-starter
ideology the Guardian Pat put out an
op-ed
a couple days ago saying that Harris has
a great centrist platform no no no
didn't we learn from 2016 and then the
hill published an op-ed by a democratic
consultant and lobbyist saying Clinton
lost in 2012 because she was moderate
and conservative voters supported Barack
Obama more okay the problem in 2016 was
partially that Hillary Clinton was to
the right of Barack Obama more centrist
and in part lots of other problems as
well they're going in the wrong
direction here I mean it's 2017 and the
Democratic Party is already setting
themselves up to lose the next
presidential election you know I think
because Trump is so scandal-ridden and
because the Republicans in Congress are
so ineffectual it gives this idea that
maybe you can just stay the course so
you don't have to go on the offense but
we've learned from 2016 that that's not
the case because Hillary Clinton
primarily ran an anti Trump campaign
correct she didn't promote any ideas of
economic populism that poll well for
broader Americans that could really get
you to the White House or just to win
majorities in Congress that's a path
that we have to take the center approach
basically means compromise right now
right center is for example when Barack
Obama starts negotiating Obamacare with
maybe a public option might be nice and
we get nothing except tens of millions
of new customers for private for-profit
insurance companies and I always like to
say this Obamacare did some good things
I've praised it for the good things it
did and I've criticized it for the bad
things that it did this will get us I
mean maybe I'm joking here president Ted
Nugent or something equivalent maybe
president Kid Rock who's running for
something up in Michigan I believe right
now this is the type of thing that will
get Trump re-elected or even worse and
I'm not saying I'm against Kamala Harris
right I mean I'm not necessarily against
her but to anoint her now with this idea
of Democratic establishment donors and
the DNC and Democrats Inc saying hey
here's who we're going to go with around
this centrist ideology we're starting to
go about 2020 the exact same
way that we went about 2016 we're seeing
the same mistakes that we saw in 2016
and by the way midterms 2018 why are we
talking about 2020 right now right it
could be hard to win a battle of
personalities against Donald Trump
especially I think that's why for the
meantime we should just focus on
specific policy proposals make a Venn
diagram of the issues that are most
important to the American people and
those that people will vote on so for
example a broader economic populist
message of things like raising the
minimum wage for example maybe reforming
trade deals all of these things will get
people to the polls and you really have
to think about what issues are
non-starters and and this is difficult
right I mean we looked at that Gallup
most important problem poll where they
asked Americans what's the most serious
or pressing issue and we saw generally
the biggest issue is distrust and
disapproval of our elected officials
just people don't really trust our
elected officials that's the big matzo
ball hanging out there that you've got
to deal with in some way health care was
at the absolute top of that list and
I've been saying it for months now
Democrats need to just say we're for
Medicare for all we've got a bill it's
HR 676 it doesn't matter that it won't
pass with a Republican House Senate and
White House but say that it's what
you're for this whole thing of well
Obamacare has some issues which we
should fix but we never actually will
but we don't want to repeal it and the
Republican replacement ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
we're for health care for everybody
here's how we pay for it it is our moral
and patriotic duty we will be the best
country when it comes to tech and
engineering and the environment and
whatever if people don't have to worry
about am I going to lose my health care
if I change jobs but you've got to do
that and then you have to consider what
issues sort of show up as important but
may not be as important of a voting
issue so immigration is one that is
often debated you could say well no
people do vote on immigration policy
because Donald Trump talked about
banning Muslims and people loved it and
he won at the same time though you have
to think about will a more reasonable
immigration position from Democrats
actually get people out and voting if
not maybe you don't make it a huge part
of your platform
when you talk about what issues are most
important to Americans right now you may
be surprised to learn that Russia
doesn't rank very high on that list and
while that is important I think because
it goes to you know the integrity of our
electoral system whether or not we have
an illegitimate president as people
often say of course maybe not mention it
on the campaign trail as much yeah and
as I said before if Russia is something
big and it pulls Trump down Trump will
be gone you can't run a run against
Trump if Russia evaporates and is
nothing you still need something else to
run against Trump or Republicans in 2018
and 2020 and what I can assure you is
this again idea of let's run in the
middle this is a recipe for disaster and
Democrats are already failing on this
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership